this video was made possible by
curiosity stream
get access to exclusive content from the
real engineering team
like the logistics of d-day series and
our new podcast
by signing up to the nebula and
curiosity bundle deal
for the amazing low price of 1479 a year
in 1991 a japanese physicist sumio ijima
conducted a momentous experiment an
experiment that introduced the world to
a material
so strong that it could revolutionize
how engineers
approached design taking two graphite
rods as electrodes
sumio applied a current across the rods
a spark arched between them
and with it a cloud of carbon gas puffed
into existence
vaporizing the tip of the anode rod as
the carbon-laden air
settled on the chamber walls it formed a
thin layer of black soot
within it a strange new material
appeared
tiny single-layer straws of carbon sumio
ejima
had just created carbon nanotubes
laboratory testing of these mysterious
little tubes in the following years
would reveal that these nanometer wide
hexagonal lattices of carbon
had the strongest tensile strength known
to man
and this was just one of many incredible
material properties
they displayed carbon nanotubes are
light conductive
and bio-compatible it soon became clear
that the carbon nanotubes
had the potential to be the building
blocks of futuristic
new technologies the most efficient
computers
transformative medical devices synthetic
muscles
are perhaps the most ambitious of all
space elevators
the dream of countless sci-fi authors
carbon nanotubes have promised
to be the catalyst for the next
revolution in technology
but putting this revolutionary material
to work
will not be easy it turns out that
building a fiber
that is actually a single molecule of
any significant length
is incredibly difficult to understand
this fascinating molecule let's dive
into the chemical makeup of carbon
nanotubes
carbon is a very familiar element it's
in
everything we eat sleep on and step over
it is the element that holds our dna
together it forms the carbohydrates
proteins and lipids
that we depend on to build and fuel our
bodies
it's the basis of life as we know it its
ubiquity
in our lives is a result of its
versatility its chemical properties
allow it to take
many different shapes each impacting its
material properties
in diverse and unique ways to understand
this
we need to understand the basic models
of how we visualize
how electrons orbit around the nucleus
of an atom
to start we have the simplified bohr
model
which separates the electrons into
shells the first shell can contain two
electrons while the second shell can
hold eight
an atom wants to fill each shell to be
stable
let's take an atom of carbon which has
six electrons
to see how this plays out first we fill
the first shell with its two electrons
then
we have four electrons left to fill the
next shell
leaving four open positions in its outer
shell
the four open positions mean the carbon
willingly interacts with many other
elements as well as itself
often by sharing electrons in a special
type of bond
called a covalent bond this versatility
allows carbon to create
many different kinds of molecules take
hydrocarbons
hydrogen has one electron and seeks one
electron to fill its inner shell
so carbon likes to form four covalent
bonds with four hydrogen atoms
to form a stable eight electron outer
shell
while helping hydrogen form a stable two
electron shell
this is methane an incredibly common
molecule
that is the main ingredient in natural
gas fuels
this is just one arrangement carbon can
take
hydrocarbons take a huge range of shapes
and configurations
but what we are interested in is how
carbon bonds to itself
but this simplified bohr model doesn't
give us an understanding of how
carbon to carbon bonds take radically
different shapes
we need to dive a little deeper before
we can understand the magic of carbon
nanotubes
electrons don't travel in neat 2d
circular orbits as the bohr model would
suggest
in fact we can't even know the position
and speed of an electron
instead we can make predictions about
electrons general locations in 3d space
we call these orbitals and they are
regions where we have about a
90 certainty that an electron is located
somewhere within that region this can
get pretty complicated but for now
we just need to concern ourselves with
two types s
and p orbitals s orbitals are spherical
in shape
with the nucleus of the atom at their
center p
orbitals are often called dumbbell
shaped but i don't know what gym these
nerds are going to
because i have never seen a dumbbell
like this
it's more of a figure of h shape like
the infinity symbol
in the ground state electrons will
occupy the lowest
energy orbitals first which in this case
is the 1s
orbital it can hold two electrons next
we have the 2s orbital
which has a larger sphere and can also
hold two electrons
then we have our three p orbitals one
aligned along the x
y and z axis each capable of holding
two electrons carbon in its ground state
has the 1s and 2s orbitals filled with
one electron in the px orbital
and one in the py orbital to be stable
carbon wants to fill these three
orbitals with two electrons each
now this is where things get a little
funky and confusing
and yes it will be on your final exam
carbon can bond to itself
in different ways that affect these
orbital shapes
take diamonds to fill these orbitals
carbon bonds with four neighboring
carbon atoms
to do this it promotes one electron from
its 2s orbital
into the empty pz orbital this pz
orbital is higher energy than the 2s one
and the electron doesn't want to stay
there so
the carbon atom takes a new hybrid
orbital shape
to compensate this is called sp3
hybridization which is a mixture of s
and p
orbital shapes and looks something like
this
where one side of the figure of 8
expands while the other contracts
the 2s and 3p orbitals are transformed
into these new sp3 orbital shapes
they repel each other equally in this 3d
space
to form this four lobed tetrahedral
shape with 109.5 degrees
between each lobe covalent bonds now
form
between the carbon molecules where these
orbital lobes overlap
head on in what's called a sigma bond
this creates a repeating structure like
this
and it's this rigid framework of carbon
atoms that makes diamond
extremely hard now what's fascinating to
me
is that you can take the same carbon
atoms and now form graphite
a material so soft that we use it as
pencil lead and as a lubricant
how does that work here a different
hybridization occurs
once again one electron from the 2s
orbital is promoted
into the pz orbital but this time the s
orbital hybridizes with only two of the
p
orbitals giving us the new sp2
hybridization
this gives us three sp hybrid orbitals
and one
regular p orbital this new arrangement
causes the orbitals to take a new shape
with the three
sp orbitals arranging themselves in a
flat plane
separated by 120 degrees with the
non-hybridized
p orbital perpendicular to them
now when the carbon atoms combine the
heads of the sp
orbitals overlap once again to form this
flat
hexagonal shape a hexagon pattern is
naturally
a very strong and energy efficient shape
for example
bees don't intentionally build
honeycombs and hexagons
they form as a result of the warm bee
bodies melting the wax
and then the triple junction hardens in
the strongest formation
the shape is frequently used in
aerospace applications
where high strength and low weight is a
priority
these sp2 bonds are stronger than sp3
bonds
because they have a higher s character
this sounds complicated but all it means
is that they are more like s orbitals
than p orbitals
because there are three sp2 bonds they
have a 33 percent
s character whereas sp3 orbitals have
four sp
bonds giving them 25 percent as
character
s orbitals are closer to the nucleus
making sp2 bonds
shorter and more electronegative than
sp3 bonds
and thus stronger this hexagonal
structure
and strong bonds makes graphene
exceedingly strong
laboratory testing of graphene using
atomic force microscopes
has shown graphene has a youngs modulus
of 0.5 tera pascals
and an ultimate tensile strength of 130
gigapascals
so strong that if we could somehow
create a perfect sheet of graphene
which we can't we could build an
invisible
single atom deep hammock that could
support the weight of a cat
imagine the amount of cats we could
confuse that's the world i want to live
in
that's an entertaining but not terribly
useful application
but graphene is a very common material
and the form we are used to
graphite is not strong this hexagonal
shape itself
is extremely strong but because graphite
forms single atom layer
sheets with only weak van der waal
forces holding them together
the sheets can easily slide over each
other which is the reason graphite is so
soft
now what is interesting is that carbon
nanotubes
take the same repeating hexagonal
structure as graphite
the ends of the sheets are simply looped
and connected together
to form a tube and this structure is
what gives carbon nanotubes their
incredible strength
researchers found that single-walled
nanotubes have similar strength
to that of graphics about 130
gigapascals
for non-engineers in the crowd let me
rephrase that
it's a lot about 100 times greater than
that of steel
and to boost it's vastly lighter if this
material could be feasibly manufactured
into a single
extremely long fiber it could
potentially open up
entirely new design possibilities like
the space elevator
i'd explain exactly why carbon fibers
would make space
elevators possible now but i already did
that in a past video that i will link at
the end of this one
so where are these space elevators
things have changed a bit
since the days of sumio ijima's first
discovery the most promising method of
industrial scale production
of high purity carbon nanotubes is
chemical vapor disposition
in this manufacturing method a precursor
gas containing carbon
like methane is introduced into a vacuum
chamber
and heated as the heat increases inside
the chamber
the bonds between the carbon and
hydrogen atoms begin to decompose
the carbon then diffuses into a melted
metal catalyst substrate
this then becomes a metal carbon
solution which eventually becomes
super saturated with carbon at this
point the carbon starts to precipitate
out and form carbon nanotubes while the
hydrogen byproduct is vented out of the
chamber
to avoid an explosion our research has
focused on increasing the length of
these nanotubes
while not sacrificing their structure
yield or quantity
while some labs have gotten individual
tubes as long as 50 centimeters
it's been a struggle to get larger
bundles of tubes
which are called forests to a length
greater than two centimeters
this is because the catalyst is
guaranteed to deactivate at some point
during the growth process terminating
the growth of the nanotube
the key to growing longer nanotubes is
minimizing the probability
of the catalyst deactivating in 2020 a
research team based in japan
managed to grow a forest over 15
centimeters in length
seven times longer than anyone else
using a new method of chemical vapor
disposition
that managed to keep the catalyst active
for 26 hours
they did this by adding a layer of
gadolinium to a conventional iron
aluminium oxide catalyst
coated on a silicon substrate then using
a lower chamber temperature
small concentrations of iron and
aluminium vapor
were added into the chamber these
factors combined
managed to keep the iron aluminium oxide
catalyst
active for much longer this method is a
major leap forward
that could allow carbon nanotube
products to begin entering the market
but we are still a long way from a space
elevator
most products today call for the fibers
to be woven together to form a yarn-like
textile
one study i found wove together one
millimeter long
nanotubes into a yarn and then
impregnated that with an epoxy resin
to form a composite material which had a
pretty good tensile strength of 1.6
gigapascals
beating aluminium in its strength to
weight capabilities
but below that of traditional carbon
fiber composites
however these new longer nanotubes may
give us stronger woven fibers in future
it's important to remember that carbon
nanotubes aren't just strong
their most exciting near-term
applications will come about
as a result of their other material
properties like their conductive
abilities
like graphite nanotubes are highly
conductive
because each carbon atom is only bonded
to three
other carbon atoms so each atom has one
free valence electron available
for electrical conduction making carbon
nanotubes
excellent conductors the conducting core
of cables that make up our overhead grid
lines are typically made from aluminium
even though aluminium is a poorer
conductor than copper
and thus causes a greater loss in power
over the lines
it's used because it's cheaper and
lighter allowing support structures for
overhead lines to be spaced further
apart
individual nanotubes are orders of
magnitude more conductive than copper
but creating a yarn of nanotubes that
could match copper has been a challenge
electrons move through individual
nanotubes very efficiently
but when the tube comes to an end the
current meets resistance when jumping to
a neighboring tube
so these longer tubes developed last
year are opening doors to conductors
that are vastly lighter than aluminium
and more conductive
than copper these could be used for grid
connections
allowing our power lines to stretch
further without supports
and minimize the loss of power to heat
resistance
but for now the price of nanotubes
likely shuts that door
instead we could see these wires being
used in super lightweight aircraft or
cars
they are even being investigated as a
means of helping composite structure
planes
like the 787 survive lightning strikes
the 787 is primarily composed of carbon
and glass fiber reinforced plastics
but because they do not conduct
electricity the plane has additional
conductive structures
added to protect it from lightning
strikes like a thin
copper mesh this mesh adds waste that
increases fuel consumption
this could be drastically reduced by
including a carbon nanotube mesh
on the surface of the composite instead
nanotubes are also
quite elastic capable of stretching to
18
of their original length and returning
to their original shape after
this could allow conductive carbon fiber
wires to be incorporated into wearable
technology
perhaps the most exciting application is
biomedical devices
carbon nanotubes are biocompatible
meaning they are not
toxic non-reactive and do not elicit
an immune response combine this with
their conductivity
flexibility and strength and nanotubes
become extremely attractive
as neural interface material a large
part of neurolink elon musk's neural
interface companies
efforts have been focusing on creating
smaller wires
and the machines needed to implant them
larger stiffer wires
tear into flexible brain tissue over
time and causes scar tissue to form
around the wire preventing signals from
passing from the neurons to the wires
nanotube wiring
could be made smaller and more flexible
while being accepted by the body
a potentially game-changing material for
biomedical implants
as with every major material innovation
from age hardened aluminium ushering in
a new age of aviation
to silicon semiconductors opening up an
entire new world for computers
carbon nanotubes have the potential to
open the door
to design possibilities and technologies
we have yet to imagine
new materials radically change how and
what we build
and learning about manufacturing
processes for complex machines
really gives you an insight on how a
material like this could change things
one of my favorite series on curiosity
stream how to build
teaches you exactly that an in-depth
series that takes you onto the
manufacturing floor of supercars
jumbo jet wings and satellites it's a
fantastic three-part series
that alone is worth the 1479 price
of curiosity stream but along with this
series
you get access to thousands of
documentaries by award-winning
filmmakers
and you will get access to nebula the
streaming service i started with 100
other
informative youtube creators like mbk hd
wendover productions and mustard nebula
is the home
of all real engineering's current and
future exclusive
content like the logistics of d-day
series and our upcoming
battle of britain series which will
release sometime
later this year by signing up for this
bundle deal
you unlock budgets for our team to
continue creating this series
and improves the quality of animations
and research we can do
right here on youtube too sign up today
for under 15 to support this channel
in the most effective way possible and
get an amazing deal for yourself
in the process if you are looking for
something else to watch right now
why not watch our last video on the
future of nuclear space propulsion
or watch real science's latest video the
insane biology of the hammerhead shark